we strive to create a space for amazing
and courageous people to share their
stories here at the show and in the wake
of the senseless attacks on the asian
community across our country
many business owners and influencers are
using their voice to speak
out against hate and injustice and we
always want to use this platform to
elevate these voices
and so i really want you to meet our
friend sarah wynn
she is the founder of win coffee supply
the first specialty vietnamese coffee
importer and roaster
in the u.s and sarah has been using her
business
to fight for racial justice one bean
at a time and sarah is here in the
studio
first of all you went to ucla and
studied asian american
studies studies what made it so
important for you to have other people's
back
and fight for what you believe in yeah i
think you know growing up in boston i
just felt so invisible
as a young vietnamese american kid and
then when i discovered activism in high
school i just
found my voice and i found my passion
for increasing representation because i
didn't have that growing up
see these are why i love hearing this
because people
it's like that's your truth about who
you are as a human being
and it's such an inspiration to other
people now here's a fun fact
vietnam number two behind
brazil for coffee production yes
i didn't know until 2016 and i was like
how do i not know this fact i'm
vietnamese-american
drew it's because of lack of
transparency and because vietnamese
coffee and farmers have been rendered
invisible in the coffee world
well let's bring this into the light
take me through this beautiful
coffee of yours yeah so i brewed you a
fiend drip coffee
you flip the cap yep the cap becomes a
coaster put it
over and i already put a dab of swinging
condensed milk for you in the bottom
you can stir it up and this is loyalty
it's our best-selling blend and it's a
blend of both arabica
and robusta which vietnam is the most
famous for
thank you for letting us shine a light
on your small business which is
really a big thing at this show i
learned so much
about how important it is to feature
small businesses
wow so it's a little stronger than usual
because robusta has two times more
caffeine than arabica coffee beans
there's
a really delicious note of like a
beautiful
bitterness that's almost like a dark
chocolate
and then i'm just getting velvet it's so
smooth
and so beautiful now how can the rest of
us
really be an ally in this time where
we want to support each other do you
have a suggestion for me
or anyone who may be watching first
check in with yourself and see if you
have certain biases or stereotypes
about asians that you don't understand
so unpack that first because change
starts inside
and the next thing is to use your voice
and your platform and your privilege to
have these conversations with other
people
because when we can start one-on-one it
creates a ripple effect of change
i also reached out to all of my friends
and i
just said what can i do how can i be
there for you
i love what you just said because it
shows that being an ally
and being a change maker it's not a
perfect path and it's not a linear path
it's about being open to learning and
stumbling and growing
i think that's just the most important
thing right and so thank you for
reaching out and
being so honest and vulnerable about
your your experience as well thank you
sarah
and are we now best friends yeah please
but we want to continue supporting all
the good work you're doing which is why
we're also gonna buy a five thousand
dollar cup of coffee
from your store and we're gonna put you
on the website the whole business
and you are i'm so honored
if you will be in our um small
businesses gift guide are you kidding me
and thank you sarah